de d'émotion puisque mois et à trois
mois de la mode
on est poussé par c'est pas évident mais
entre sherlock ou parce qu'on a de jouer
dans notre vie et avec dieu en a la
force le courage d'avancer parce qu'il
faut qu'on aille de l'avant et avec les
enfants c'est tout le plaisir pour mon
cette cérémonie pour honorer son nom
parce que c'est un homme qui aimait son
métier de pompier maître qui était
toujours là pour dévouer son aide à tous
quel métier des droits ce qui fait que
c'est la cérémonie c'est un son honneur
il nous sommes fiers d'être là avec avec
sophie sermonné celle où célébrer ce
moment c'est important pour vous de le
reconnaître le travail des sapeurs
pompiers ça même sens un moment ça a
toujours été important pour nous
françois quand même ce sont des des
hommes qui se livrent à tout un chacun
dans les moments de besoin d'eux ils
sont toujours là au moment accident au
feu haute alors même pas de l'inde
la supervision sur moment c'est des gens
que nous avons toujours respecté